Hey, yo, no matter what, dawg,
don't snitch.
Okay, I ain't
saying nothing, dude.
You know me.
I'd die
before I turn snitch.
You tell them nothing,
they got nothing.
Yeah.
You think
J-Rock talking?
Hell no, dawg.
J-Rock is my cousin.
That man would never snitch.
(J-Rock)
All right,
so just chill out here?
Cool.
Hey, bring that ice when
you get that chance, Dwight.
All right, man.
[laughs]
You the man, Dwight.
Sss...bitch-ass cop.
What up, J-Rock?
They hurt you
up in there?
What you mean,
"hurt you"?
Look like he just got back
from the fucking snack shop.
What you say
to them, man?
[suspenseful music]
Nothing.
You lying piece of sh--
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
This is my man
right here, a'ight?
My brother.
This man ain't never
snitch on nobody, never.
Whatever.
Now, look...
We in this together,
right, hmm?
Nobody says nothing, right?
- Right.
Nobody gonna say nothing
about how Big Earl
shot up that liquor store.
No, no, no.
It wasn't Big Earl.
What the hell
are you talking about?
It wasn't?
Hell no.
Buckshot's the one
that held up that liquor store.
Buckshot.
♪ ♪
[muttering]
Now where's he going?
I don't know,
maybe he's going
to the bathroom
or some shit.
Man, he's going in there
to snitch on us.
No, no, listen,
let me tell you something.
That's my boy right there.
We grew up together.
That is a stand-up G.
That man
would never snitch.
Pizza time!
Pizza time, pizza time.
Everybody love
pizza time.
♪ Wake up in the morning,
it's pizza time ♪
♪ Go ahead and eat it,
♪ Pizza, pizza,
p-pizza time ♪
Motherfucking pig-ass cop,
man.
- Oh, no.
- Hold on, hold on.
- Snitch--
Now, J-Rock, um...
where'd you get the pizza?
Yeah.
Back there.
I--I--
I bought it.
You know what,
listen to me.
This ain't no fucking game,
okay?
If I find out
you done snitched on us,
I'm gonna bust a cap
in your tiny
pizza-breath ass,
and then I'm gonna bury you
in my mother's basement
with the rest
of the snitches.
- [muttering]
- What?
No, what'd he say?
What'd he say?
Where you going?
Where you going now?
Where you g--
Oh, see, see?
See, look, look.
Look, he's selling me out
right now.
No, no, no, he's saying
that "I would never
sell out that man."
What?
I'm telling you.
All right, let's go.
- Let's go, come on.
- Oh, hell, man.
See, what'd I tell you,
Rockwell, huh?
What I tell you?
You snitch-ass--
♪ Roll with me,
roll with me ♪
♪ Let the night unfold ♪
[horn beeps]
- What the--
- ♪ With me ♪